by the time you get to the office you've
been awake for two three hours so by the
time you get there like you're already
hitting a bit of a slump sometimes
nav powers commute is a weary one it's
only 30 minutes but it takes over an
hour
welcome to bradford the worst connected
city in the uk
the government promised voters faster
trains between leeds and manchester with
bradford at the heart of it cutting
journey times in half
today those plans were scaled back used
to live down south and
trains are completely different to the
trains up north like they're just so
much better my frequent like
tend to run a lot more on time
the whole of your life would change if
this train just went a bit faster yeah a
lot of people will benefit from it so
when you hear that the government are
saying actually the big promise that
we've made
we're actually not going to go through
with it
what's your reaction to that
[Music]
i mean i'm used to it there's so many
things that they said that they're going
to do that never happened so this is
just another one for the list really
nav is one of thousands of commuters who
are looking forward to a better rail
service they were after all promised it
by the government now what's on offer is
a massively watered down version of that
and this has huge implications for the
government's big domestic policy and
that is to level up britain
the labour leader sakia starmer and the
mayor of west yorkshire took what can
only be described as a somber tour
around what would have been bradford's
brand new railway station
those plans have now been torn up if you
miss out bradford if you promise us npr
and then don't deliver unfortunately
that is a betrayal of the north the
government had this on the table i just
wonder as one of the key figures in this
region whether you take any
responsibility for not being able to
hold the government to their promises
and to bring a big infrastructural
project to here i mean do you take any
responsibility for this well six months
into the job i've been since may
absolutely challenging government
where's the integrated rail plan where
is it the problem with this government
is that they can announce and then
u-turn in six months time this doesn't
work for the north you're absolutely not
not leveling up this is leveling down
the government have promised that the
revised plans between leeds and
manchester will be delivered sooner
cheaper
the problem with promises here is too
many have come and gone
nick martin sky news bradford